hey what's going on it's bill burns it's
time for the thursday afternoon just
before friday monday morning podcast and
i'm just checking in on you how are you
this is going to be a bit of a quiet
podcast
because i'm in a hotel room out here on
the jersey show
and my wife's still sort of sleeping but
not really maybe giving me a dirty look
no staring at her phone um yeah i'm out
here
in um new jersey and uh
i did a bunch of shows well i did two
shows monday
the two on tuesday got rained out
and then i did two last night my voice
is fried from uh
screaming like a lunatic but um
i think we're gonna try to make up those
shows friday night provided that it does
not rain
uh it's been a wonderful trip back here
i want to thank everybody who showed up
i want to thank everyone that i worked
with the great joe bartnick
the amazing tony v and one of the best
guys in the business
jim florente uh tony v worked on the
first leg and florentine did the jersey
shows we had so much fun
just hanging out it was great to be able
to do shows and make people laugh
jersey's been a trip you know had some
great italian food out
here great people watching uh not the
biggest state on masks
i guess they only had one person die so
um i just don't understand where hey man
the numbers are really dipping and then
they sort of
loosen up on the mask thing just so they
can create another spike i just don't
[ __ ] get it
keep your [ __ ] masks on until it's
gone
why don't they do that you know why
because people [ __ ] whine
so i mean it's it's all right
it's all a conspiracy man it doesn't
exist they're overreacting all these
non-scientists just saying all of this
[ __ ]
um non-scientists looking up
scientific information on the internet
which is just full of [ __ ] people
spinning [ __ ] the way that they want to
spin it
yeah why listen to guys who are actually
scientists
in a lab working for the cdc why would
you do that when you can listen to your
friend who [ __ ] plows snow
who went on the internet and found some
conflicting information well good for
you pal did you do that
in between looking at free porn by all
means let the world listen to you
um but anyway great time out here we
stayed in uh
long branch new jersey and drove down to
asbury park yesterday
went to that great arcade right across
the street from uh
what is it the stone pony the famous
rock venue where i believe bruce
springsteen e street band and all of
them
started and uh
[Music]
got a couple of nathan's hot dogs and
just went in there played pinball
brought my daughter around she was
having a blast my wife talked all of
this crap going um they got skee-ball
here she goes i'm gonna kick your ass in
skee-ball and i'm like
and i'm like what is skee-ball she just
goes and i did it
and i did it thinking i'm gonna like
tell some different story over here
um first of all you didn't kick my ass
yes
yeah when you play best two out of three
and you win two games to one and you win
the last game on the last two balls i
wouldn't say you
you won you didn't kick my ass and uh
anytime you want a rematch
that was me just i i never really even
played that game
yeah i never did i got that good i got
that good so anytime you want to come
back to [ __ ] asbury park and have a
round two
maybe put a little money on it i'm up
for it do it
yeah i never heard of that and what's
funny is there's a character on f is for
family called skee-ball and i never
i never even knew what that meant um
and now i do skee-ball is a game that
your wife's good at and she barely beats
you
and then talks [ __ ] about it for [ __ ]
24 hours
no she was actually really good at it
and she was very competitive and was
very attractive to see that trait you
know
usually she's just sitting around the
couch bitching at me
i know trying to get her up to get over
here
um so anyways uh
they had all these old-school games in
there they had that um
that driving game grand prix whatever
the [ __ ] it was called
we just have high and low gear in your
gas pedal
that was it no clutch stood up when you
did it they have the
gun game they had a they had a 1976
uh hugh hefner playboy
pinball machine uh they had a
an elton john one from the 70s a kiss
one from the 70s they just had all these
great pinball machines
um and then frogger all of the games
that i [ __ ]
you know my parents wouldn't let me play
when i was growing up but i could play
them over my friend's house
so we had a great time doing that i flew
uh me and my daughter we flew a kite
first time my daughter ever flew a kite
first time i've flown a kite since like
the i don't know
80s early 80s maybe i was like how the
hell do you do this
i had the thing upside down because i
was looking at the picture
oh sorry looking at the picture on top
of the kite
like a dope and it's just and i knew
enough i literally had to use my pilot's
license going like this is not producing
lift
rather than being like hey stupid
it's gonna go up in the air so the
picture faces face down you
dumb freckled [ __ ] so i finally figured
that out and we had a great time with
that
made like sand castles and uh all of
that stuff
and uh i don't know we had a great time
out here in jersey and i get it now
you know the jersey shore gets like such
a bad rap
especially by like you know new yorkers
who feel that they're a cut above
from the animal that is out here in new
jersey and just to let you know you know
i've been to [ __ ] new jersey i've
lived in new york and
it's i don't know as far as an outsider
you're all the same people i don't see
what the animosity is
uh jersey shore is beautiful
and way more affordable than that uh
maybe that's what it is
because the jersey shore generally
speaking
because we did drive through deal new
jersey with these
gigantic they were mansions
and that i guess were people's summer
homes this is my
summer home on ocean boulevard look it
up deal new jersey they're all like turn
of the
last century mansions
that these people have where they just
you know that's what they do in the
summer time i guess i have no idea
um so i guess it's uh
like the hamptons is for new yorkers who
like
really really [ __ ] screwed people and
stole money
and then like the jersey shores for like
new yorkers and people in jersey who you
know
did their thing whatever
i'm just [ __ ] with you but i just
don't know how you make that kind of
money
legally and actually pay your taxes
um i didn't see that part of the debate
the presidential debate which
i don't really want to get into because
i i was actually for the first time ever
actually happy with what cnn said at the
end of it
because i figured they were just going
to trash trump and they were just like i
didn't get anything out of that that was
just a train wreck
they didn't say one good thing about
either guy
oh god i mean that was just
i don't understand how like it's at the
presidential level and they don't have
the technology to just turn down the
guy's mic
if one person just keeps interrupting
like how hard is that how many times
that's been done to me as a comedian
they wanted me off stage and i wouldn't
get off stage for whatever reason
they flashed the light and then after
the light that's it they just
cut off the mic over um
for some reason they didn't do it and i
love so loved like when
either person was talking they they kept
a split screen the whole time so you
could see the other person
it was almost like they it was just they
knew it was going to be a spectacle
um i don't know
you didn't you didn't pay your taxes you
found a loophole he just goes i'm smart
[Laughter]
it's like watching two kids in a high
school cafeteria
oh my god and then he brings up his dead
son and the one who's got a coke problem
it's like jesus christ
or he's like i don't know the dead one
i'm talking about the one with the coke
problem
it's like ladies
i don't know and i love that there's
still people that feel great about the
candidate that they're gonna vote for
after that it's like
you know the whole thing the whole
[ __ ] thing they're not wearing masks
they're looking at those two [ __ ]
being a liberal and expect
accepting the fact that they're shoving
[ __ ] joe biden down your goddamn
throat what's that guy [ __ ] 90 years
old
with a facelift he looked like the
goddamn [ __ ] keeper
bumbling and stumbling through his words
and then trump is sitting there with
this [ __ ]
scowl on his face he looked like he was
out of a fairy tale
the grumpy banker the entire time
and just beyond rude
they said he interrupted like over 70
times
and i think that there is no [ __ ] way
that guy's not going to win kids he just
appeals to the mouth-breathing [ __ ]
good he should interrupt the other guy's
got nothing to say
biden shucks trump 2020 you know
um i don't know i've seen like
more courteous behavior watching
wrestling
it's just it was just an absolute
uh [ __ ] disaster and i can't believe
in four years the dumb democrats you
couldn't just come up with a
40-something year old
like they did with clinton just to go
change
people american people won't change
play a little fleetwood mac and then
it's [ __ ] over just have some 40 old
dude
and just go in there and play some music
from the 80s as trump is saying all this
grumpy [ __ ]
instead they go out and as far as i
could tell i haven't looked up their
ages
they found a guy even [ __ ] older
so the bright side is is where
when trump gets reelected we'll at least
be half
over we'll be half done with the guy who
won't denounce
white supremacists oh my god that was
such a low point when they go
uh do you will you denounce
white supremacy he goes absolutely they
go all right do it
and he's like you know a long time ago
and he just blows past it
and then the other two guys are like
school girls going who say it well then
do it again the whole [ __ ] thing
i don't know i i yeah jesus christ
sophie's choice coming up november 4th
whenever the hell they're gonna have it
but let's get on to some better news
here
everybody uh the tampa bay lightning
your tampa bay lightning
i believe it was four games to two i've
been working every night
but i work with the great joe bartnick
so he keeps me up on all the hockey news
um congratulations to them their second
stanley cup victory which is really
impressive
considering there's this many teams 30
teams
and that they've won uh they've won two
within 30 years of their existence
no when did tampa bay lightning come out
let me see tampa bay
lightning i thought it was the 90s
am i crazy tampa bay light lightning
stanley cup ornament
i don't know what the [ __ ] that is um
let's get to wiki there you are
all right establish founded 1992
there you go so in 28 years
they've won two stanley cups they're
averaging one every 14 years
and considering there's 30 teams if you
average one once every 30 years i figure
that's got to be like
average so they're uh
doubling that sort of maybe a little bit
more that's that's great good for them
congratulations i respect the lightning
i hate them because they always seem to
beat my bruins but uh
congratulations um condolences to dallas
star fans i've been there
i was there last year at least they put
you out of your misery in six games you
didn't have to go
seven um yeah
and with that the uh
the chicago cleveland orlando new
orleans
los angeles lakers are up one game to
none
against the miami heat
i hope the miami heat bought enough guys
to beat all the guys that the lakers
bought
of course their two highest scorers are
not lakers i just [ __ ] it's just
killing me as a celtics fan just
watching daddy warbucks out there with
the [ __ ] hollywood [ __ ] in the
sunshine
they're gonna win another one i hope not
i hope that he beat him but whatever you
know something i've kind of given up on
uh
i'm trying to give up on just actually
hating
teams to the level that i used to
because it's just such a [ __ ] waste
of energy and i'm not going to be able
to control any of it
let me see if the indians beat the
yankees last night indians verse
cleveland it was a great game was eight
to eight before the old man billy fell
asleep oh they came back
what it was eight to eight then it was
nine to eight when i went to bed
and they started walking people
oh my god the yankees not only scored a
run in the top of the ninth they scored
two
to close them out and your cleveland
indians
72 years in to this drought
jesus christ um
yankees move on um
with their great team i don't know i got
a good feeling about them this year
i haven't watched too much baseball but
i saw what they did last year with all
of their homegrown talent and all of
that
um even as a red sox fan if they win
this one i can't hate on it
like i always make fun of the red sox
and yankees championships
from like 98 on whereas just write it up
free agents
from around the league so many of them
from cleveland
um i just found i remember that [ __ ] i
just found that funny one there when the
yankee fans were bitching about the
[ __ ] astros
it's like really they banged on a
[ __ ] trash can come on
what are we doing here um anyway oh
jesus this has just been me just like
[ __ ] moaning and complaining you know
what it is i'm a little grumpy because
i'm [ __ ] tired
and now i gotta pack and uh go to the
airport and uh get on a plane fly across
this guard forsaken country one more
time
and i'm gonna be flying uh i guess when
you get into the airport everybody will
mirror the mask but like these [ __ ]
[ __ ] who wear the mask
and then they have it still below their
nose so they can breathe
they're just such [ __ ] like how much
of a [ __ ] [ __ ] are you that you
can't breathe in
i can't breathe yeah you can't breathe
you just feel you just it's it's an
inconvenience and you don't want to do
it
it's why when you go to the gym you
never lose weight because you don't you
don't have the [ __ ] heart
to stick it i am the fact that we all
get graded
on it on on a [ __ ]
all get graded the same in this thing
that's what bugs me
because there's no way to create
separation from yourself doing the right
thing and a [ __ ] dope
um all right i got it all out of me but
haven't said that my act is uh
back up to where it needs to be and i
plan on doing some more of these runs
i don't care if i have to wear a jacket
during the second show like i've been
doing i've been having a great time
all right here we go simply safe
everybody simply safe
something we're not going to be if when
either one of these idiots wins the
[ __ ] election
um simply safe here's the thing about
home security companies
most trap you with high prices tricky
contracts and
lousy customer support so while there
are a lot of options out there there's
only one
no-brainer simply safe simply safe's got
everything you need to protect your home
and none of the drawbacks of traditional
home security it's got an arsenal of
sensors and cameras to blanket
every room window and door tailored
specifically for your home
professional monitoring keeps watch
day and night ready to send police fire
or medical professionals
if there's an emergency you can set it
up yourself in under an hour just peel
and stick the sensors
exactly where you need them no
technician required
and there's no contract no pushy sales
guy no hidden fees no fine print
all this starts at fifteen dollars a
month um
i'm not the only one who thinks simply
safe is great us news and world report
named it the best overall home security
of 2020. try simply safe today at simply
you get a free hd security camera
there's nothing to lose that's
simplysafeburr.com
oh look who's back it's stamps.com
everybody one of the originals
um the original six as we slowly adjust
as we slowly adjust to the new normal
trying to live our best lives while
being on the right side of history
sorry uh we still need to be smart
i'm smart i'm smart i cheat
i find a loophole on my taxes i'm smart
we still need to be smart about how we
do business um
actually his accountant smart i mean
what are you doing you're finding a
loophole
you're stealing from thieves the federal
reserve
luckily there's stamps.com to make
things easier
they've been able to keep their business
businesses running and avoid the crowds
at the post
office all from their own computers
stamps.com
also offers ups services with discounts
of up to 62 percent
how do you think they came up with 62
percent nia
61 wasn't enough in 63 that's a deal
breaker
uh you've heard me talk about stamps.com
they've sponsored the show for over
seven years now
and if you haven't tried it what are you
waiting for stamps.com brings all the
mailing and shipping services you need
right to your computer in the comfort of
your own home and office
whether you're a small business sending
invoices whether you wear a mask whether
you don't wear a mask an online seller
shipping out products or just working
from home and need to mail stuff
stamps.com can handle it all with these
simply use your computer to print us
official us postage 24 7 for any letter
any package
any class of mail anywhere you want to
send it
once your mail is ready just leave it
for your mail carries schedule
carrier schedule a pickup or drop it in
a mailbox
it's that simple and like i said with
stamps.com
you get great discounts two five cents
off every stamp
up to 62 percent off united states
postal service
and united parcel service shipping rates
stamp.com is a no-brainer saving you
time and money right now
my listeners get a special offer that
includes a four-week trial
plus free postage and a digital scale
without any long-term commitment
just go to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the home page
and type in bur that's stamps.com
enter bur all right back to the podcast
um so anyway uh
i gotta i gotta get back on the plane
fly across this
lovely nation and get back to l.a that's
on fire
i was making fun of everybody back east
here about all that stuff i was like you
know hollywood's on fire right now and i
got a sneaking
suspicion all you guys out here think
it's kind of funny
and they all laughed and i called them
out and they're [ __ ]
it's like every time you have a
hurricane and it knocks down your gazebo
right
or somebody's born with three [ __ ]
right feet and they need an operation
and you gotta raise money who do you
call on you call on
the elitist [ __ ] of hollywood and we
all come running out there with our
botox faces and our fake tits
and we go out there and we raise money
and you guys say thanks we appreciate it
and all of this
phony [ __ ] and the next thing you
know we're in the middle of hell's fire
out there and you guys are all laughing
your balls off you don't give a [ __ ]
you know all those states along the gulf
when you have hurricanes we're always
there raising money for you
all of a sudden l.a has a pro [ __ ] them
let it fall into the ocean
let me remind you we are part of this
great nation
whatever is happening to us will
eventually happen to you and you got way
more trees in your area so you think if
there's a [ __ ] fire out there
which is another reason why i don't want
this [ __ ] orange-headed dope to win
you know forget about the part that he's
just
divides people i just can't deal with
the fact that this guy
you know he just doesn't give a [ __ ]
gonna sweep up the force sweep up the
forest
what in the [ __ ] is this guy talking
about
um they're still all blowing the bankers
in the oil companies
and i don't think joe biden will be any
different um
i wish just mike pence was running and
that other chick whatever her [ __ ]
name is
what's what's the lady running with joe
biden here
kamala harris kama kama kama kama
harris
i just wish they would debate why can't
we just get people that still have blood
in their face
i've never seen i don't need to see all
the blue
veins in some old person's face that's
why
trump's smart enough to have that paint
roller a [ __ ]
tanner put on his face um
jesus christ that was like watching uh
i don't know what one of those old
walter math out jack lemon movies
towards the end of both their lives god
bless each one of them but jesus christ
the sunshine boys
one's getting too much sunshine the
other guy needs some some vitamin e
over there um all right well let's look
at the mlb playoffs while we can
playoffs i actually love baseball
as far as uh i love the playoffs
i also like watching a game i know
people [ __ ] on it san diego
padres lou 740 the cardinals the yankees
close out they've put the
indians out of their misery ten to nine
congratulations to them
the dodgers making another run
win four to two up one
game to none oh
atlanta leads the reds one game to none
those games are all on today maybe i'll
get
a plane like a jet blue type of deal
where i can watch one of the games here
the florida marlins
up one game to none now you want to talk
about a successful friggin franchise
right
they've already won two world series
they're at it again
let's see miami marlins aka
the florida marlins miami marlins
um wiki you know what's great about this
is a bunch of my relatives got to come
down
and meet their grandson their cousin
their
nephew it was a great time and they all
freaked out
when they saw my mother was so cute
she's like he's gorgeous
he is go he is gorgeous
that made me feel great uh florida
marlins
1993 ah they came out a year after the
tampa bay lightning
look at them 27 years in the league
they won two world series however in
their first 10 years
i'll tell you that was tough as a red
sox fan when they won it again
they won it 97 in 2003 and we
choked away that game seven to the
yankees in 2003.
it was great because they beat the
yankees but that was that was a tough
one
i'll tell you that was a rough one um
i'm going to start watching some of this
[ __ ]
some of these uh these teams sonya did
you have fun on this trip
you did have fun right you came out you
you put your time in you saw one of my
shows
out on the farm was it uh was it
everything you
hoped it was gonna be
what do you mean you won the first game
i won the second game and you won the
third game in the last two throws
that was really amazing i was like just
really in the zone
wow felt good felt real good how about
we play again and next time we'll put
money on it
let's do it you think i'm scared you
think i'm afraid i'm the skee-ball
[ __ ] champion
i'll smack you in the face with my
skills
all right maybe we'll film it maybe we
will
maybe we'll put money on it i'm trying
to ratchet up the pressure here on you
see how you perform i'm not scared i
thrive under pressure baby
i don't know i always doubt people that
say that i'm not scared i thrive under
pressure
oh you don't want to deal with me why i
otta
you don't want this smoke
yeah jesus um that was such an old
person fun arcade
what was the name of the place star
silver ball
star ball it's right across the street
we're diagonally from the uh
the stone pony which i guess they are
doing shows they have outdoor shows that
they can put a uh
i guess the go-go's came down it did
like 4 000 people or something i love
how
jersey is just stuck in the 80s like
when we were sitting there i swear to
god it was like i was back in time i was
time i was sitting there eating a hot
dog
and nathan's which i shouldn't be doing
and they played like that
phil collins song what song was it
oh shoot it was a deep visible touch
yeah she seems to have an invisible
touch
i remember that took me back to a long
time ago i used to work at this
warehouse
it's called corporate software i don't
think it exists anymore
yeah oh geez with the warehouse story
and there was a guy that i worked with
who loved phil collins and they just
could not play philly
they played phil collins like every
other song
and uh and i just remember when that
[ __ ] song came on
it was so goddamn happy she seems to
have
an invisible touch and he used to sing
along to it i used to hate when not the
ladies would say
invisible touch he would say invisible
touch or is it touched yeah i don't know
what it was but he would be singing it
next to me we were both facing this wall
shipping out
computer software you know filling these
orders picking him or whatever and he
used to [ __ ] sit there
singing it he was a good dude but it
drove me up the wall and he knew it and
he would just [ __ ] go all out
that's what i think of when i think of
phil collins nia
uh yeah you're gonna help me limp
through the last [ __ ] three minutes
of this [ __ ]
as i'm sitting here with heartburn from
all the goddamn how much did i eat the
other night
we got to give them a shout out what was
the name of that restaurant
[Music]
it's an italian joint yeah right on
right on the boardwalk here
we got the eggplant for uh
the appetizer yeah which was incredible
then we got uh i got the uh
filet mignon with the uh whipped
potatoes and the uh
garlic uh spinach
and you got the the short rib pasta
you're a short rib ragu and then we
finished it off with the tiramisu
with a little bit of uh with vanilla
gelato because i'm not a big i'm not a
big coffee guy i'm not a big tiramisu
fan necessarily but there was something
in me that said
get a side of gelato with it and baby
and you listened to that voice today
here on oprah we're talking about
listening to that inner voice you know
everybody has an inner voice but
just the way society for whatever reason
is set up
uh join my book club the why why every
society
is set up it just it really
i feel like it it attacks your abilities
just hear me out to listen to that voice
and today
we actually have someone who for the
longest time
never listened to her in her voice and
listened to it the other day
and according to her kicked her
husband's ass
in skee-ball ladies and gentlemen
on the oh podcast network we have mia
hill
nia thank you so much for listening to
your interviews and coming on here oh my
god thank you so much for having me this
is
truly an honor now i don't want to be a
jerk but you only beat your husband on
the last two throws so how
is that kicking his ass you know what it
is
you know what it is i'm a billionaire
woman who started in the 80s and a woman
of color so i know what kicking ass is
and you don't
and i brought you on your show to tell
you that why don't you be a little nicer
to your husband
i'm oprah winfrey and i've just listened
to my inner voice
how dare you how dare you what how dare
you trash
i didn't trash oprah winfrey what the
20th time
in your stand-up career wow bill i was
trashing you
really bringing it back to the old
classic bill bird bits
i was trashing you so well by the way
have aged so well
my god how do you just have your finger
on the pulse bringing that back an oprah
joke that's great
that's really good i was trashing you
let me tell you something
you don't trash me okay
i trash you that's how it goes down
is that how it goes down when you're
living with the skee-ball champion
that's right you and your ham radio
podcast
[Music]
podcast stinks it does this podcast is
reversed joe rogan
joe rogan now has a incredible studio it
looks like at the bottom of a nuclear
silo and i'm [ __ ] sitting here with
my little
radio shack handheld step it up so we
can get a hundred million dollars what
are you doing
no no right there on the table no
no everybody in entertainment makes that
mistake
i remember when oh well joe joe did that
i'll do what joe i'm not joe
that's like when dane cook got on
[ __ ] myspace
got a zillion fans and then sold out
myspace and every comic was like well
then i will get on myspace and it's like
you're not dane
that's the deal this works for me nia my
little pirate radio [ __ ] podcast
i'm an anti-social prick and i don't
want to book
guests i don't mind having them but just
dealing with the uh
two minutes away buddy text i just don't
want to deal with that i didn't get in
this business to work
as you can tell from the laziness of
this podcast and this is the podcast i
did exactly
well i did 32 minutes i gave you two
extra minutes all right thank you to
everybody in joycy
thank you to everybody in connecticut
that came down to the shows and uh i had
a great time thank you to all the
promoters
um and thank you to club soda kenny
you know keeping the laughs coming along
rolling along there that's it
go [ __ ] yourselves have a great weekend
you [ __ ]
i will check in on you on uh
no no i'll just talk to you on monday
that's what it's going to be
all right see you
hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
the monday morning podcast for monday
october 1st
2012 um first day of october
i got a question for you when is the
[ __ ] summer gonna end
you know i don't want to be these guy
one of these guys who the first time
there's a [ __ ] heat wave
starts going see there's global warming
i think i proved my point you know like
when it snows in february
and the people who don't believe in
global warming go like well gee what
happened to global warming it's [ __ ]
snowing out yeah it's supposed to
it's supposed to it's [ __ ] january
you dumb [ __ ]
um yeah i'm going out to la and we're
gonna have another five
day [ __ ] heat wave like 99 [ __ ]
degrees
every goddamn day and uh i don't have
air conditioning in my house
you're gonna laugh at me now you know i
kind of live
in an area where we get a nice breeze
and i was told that
by the people who i bought the house off
of that yeah that's really not a problem
can you believe that they were deceitful
you know what sucks about having a
[ __ ] house is every time you think
you got everything
fixed you know
it just something else comes along i
thought i was finally caught up i
widened the doors in the garage
i got the goddamn hot water [ __ ]
thing outside i went tankless
i got that done i fixed the [ __ ]
cabinets
you know i got screens on the windows
the [ __ ] else did i do i got the stupid
[ __ ] thing fixed that you know the
hot air goes out of on the laundromat
on the on the on the dryer all these
little [ __ ] knick-knack
[ __ ] things and i was thinking all i
got to do now
is have somebody [ __ ] get my chimney
up to code
and then clean out some other goddamn
thing and i was done now
and i gotta put a new roof on it too
so i'm thinking all right the roof
that's the most expensive thing i'll get
that thing done
right what's the point of fixing
everything else if it's just gonna get
wet
right figure that was my next move
then out of [ __ ] nowhere i got nia
calling me up
can we just get one of those stand-alone
units
can we just get ac in one room
unbelievable i thought i was in the
clear it's [ __ ] october
look who's kidding who i live in a
goddamn desert at some point i'm gonna
have to get air conditioning
but now i'm also feeling like a [ __ ]
because everybody else whoever owned my
[ __ ] house
they somehow dealt with it maybe sat on
the front steps drinking a
mint julep socializing with the
neighbors
talking about pearl harbor or whatever
the [ __ ] they did
were they a tougher breed back then or
is this global warming thing actually uh
uh something that's true well actually
it is getting warmer you know it's just
the debate is
i'm so in over my head just just just
enter entertain me just go with me on
this
the big debate is whether or not
human beings have an effect on it i just
you know you know what's funny
is i can't even take myself seriously
because every time i try to talk about a
heavy subject my brain is just screaming
at me
you don't read or you haven't read up on
any of this you've only overheard
conversations
so why don't you shut the [ __ ] up um
anyways this is a podcast for this week
everybody it's football sunday i'm here
in jacksonville florida
it's five minutes to one five minutes
before
[Music]
all the games are gonna start i already
predicted on my twitter account that the
patriots were going to win 63 to 5
today against the buffalo bills and i
stand by that
that's actually what i'm hoping is going
to happen and somebody said are you
predicting you're going to get a safety
no what's going to happen is we're going
to be up 63 to 3.
our punter's going to feel bad for you
so he's just going to kind of run out of
the back of the end zone
you know just to give you another two
[ __ ] points
you know you know what's the worst thing
about going to a buffalo bills game
aside from the lingering sadness of
losing four super bowls in a row
is listening to that dumb chant that
let's go
buffalo i hate [ __ ]
first of all it rhymes you know
yay let's go buffalo
the afc east has some of the worst
[ __ ] chants
in just in all of professional sports
e t s jets chats chats
hooray it's like what [ __ ] year is it
let's go buffalo those are some angry
[ __ ] out there i'll tell you
that me and verzie a few years ago we
went to that
[ __ ] bills jets game somebody pushed
me in the back while i was taking a piss
because i had a patriots hat on
you know [ __ ] losers out there man
[ __ ] losers
you know i love how they act like they
didn't have video cameras out there
you know [ __ ] mob levy could have
easily just filmed the other team
and won one of those super bowls you
didn't want to do it
you didn't want to do it you made me
film you
i didn't want to do it why didn't they
just you know
listen buffalo if you could learn
anything
from some of your your compadres here in
the afc east
if you can't beat them cheat
for the love of god how long are you
going to have that mom and pop store
we're making our own jam
putting it in an extra [ __ ] pickle
jars vibe
first of all you know what your problem
is buffalo you don't even deserve
a professional [ __ ] franchise do you
understand that
do you understand how if you didn't
have the bills in the sabers that the
amount of people
wouldn't even know like you'd be like
elmira you'd be one of those [ __ ]
towns nobody even knew about
you guys [ __ ] peaked back when people
took
road like when going to niagara falls
was was was like a [ __ ] you know
place where you went on your honeymoon
because the regular joe couldn't afford
to fly
all right that's why you've never won
anything
because god forgets that you exist
why am i being so mean to them i
actually think i'm going to be
performing there next year
i have no idea actually the reality is
with this whole [ __ ] patriots defense
i you know
when we got a rookie [ __ ] trying to
protect tom brady's blind side i got i
have no idea and it's a divisional
rivalry
we usually go one and one against the
bills you know the bills usually win one
and then shred and reagan called me up
like yeah did you see the game what'd
you think about that right they get all
[ __ ] excited
they start talking super bowl and then
the next time we play them we rape them
you know we put that red ball
thing in their mouth bend them over and
shove the football right up their ass
you know it's coming
you know it is
who has more false hope a bills fan or a
jets fan
i think it's the jets fan just because
they look like that guy
uh the mush in a bronx tale like your
average
[ __ ] jets fan that's what he that's
what he looks like you know and i'm not
saying that the average patriots fan
doesn't look like a [ __ ] alcoholic
lucky charms
[ __ ] dude i'm not even saying that i
would never
try to say that we don't look like a
bunch of [ __ ] drunk potatoes
all right i'm not saying that we don't
all right
but you guys just have that let's go
like off track
betting that's what you're that's what
the upper deck of a jets game looks like
[Laughter]
i don't know if it's those awful [ __ ]
green jerseys
you know if you're to get the jets
jersey you got to get
you got to get the white one man with
the green numbers when it's that
[ __ ] just pea soup
forest green
that's just one of the worst [ __ ]
jerseys ever but you know what at the
end of the day
it's still a great game see i went
positive there
at the end of the day it's still a great
game
actually going to some fight with some
[ __ ] jackoff on twitter
right because i announced i i
i tweeted that i was going to be going
to the jacksonville jaguars
cincinnati bengals game can you [ __ ]
believe that i'm hanging around an extra
day in jacksonville
to watch that contest okay
is that not going to be one of the most
lowest rated football games of the year
um do i have the hiccups jesus christ
um but anyways i got into this twitter
argument with some guy over
i'm guessing he's from [ __ ] great
britain or ireland or some [ __ ] and
and once again like those guys are so
on their own dicks if they if they
[ __ ] watch
rugby you know what i mean
like the the oh the amount of time
either there's soccer fans over there
and then they always come up with they
think it's the most clever
seinfeld thing ever they're always like
why
do they call it football when they use
it
you know like the excitement
in their emails or their their tweets
when they send that to me is if they're
the first person
who ever came up with that little clever
analogy
you know first of all
football came out of soccer we were
kicking the ball around
you know playing your dumb little
[ __ ] game that was brought over
okay but because we're [ __ ] americans
and we know we know how to [ __ ] make
[ __ ] exciting
we know how to ramp [ __ ] up we're not
stuck in the past like you guys with
your dumb
[ __ ] castles talking about oh henry
he's told [ __ ] lilliputian who gives
a [ __ ]
huh you dumb ass [ __ ] history of the
goddamn
serfs and the landowners in the feudal
system
huh and you [ __ ] catholics first
protestants
nobody gives a [ __ ] you half horse half
[ __ ] man walking around with that
[ __ ]
flute or whatever the hell it did you
bunch of goddamn perverts
a shirtless man coming out of a horse
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
you're gonna sit here and criticize our
game sitting there saying that
that that nfl that rugby
is a tougher game than nfl football
you know what rugby looks like to me
rugby looks like
nfl football if the fans ran on the
field and started playing
not saying they're not tough fans not
saying they're not fans who have gold
mem
gold gym memberships i'm not even trying
to say that i wouldn't insult you
by trying to say that i'm just saying it
just looks like
like really fast people from the stands
went out there during halftime kind of
like when you watch an nhl game and they
let those those [ __ ] kids come out
and play a little mini one on one right
we got [ __ ] swamp scott vs marblehead
today
he shoots he scores
right i'm not saying rugby isn't a tough
game i'm not saying it's not a beautiful
game and i'm not saying it's not at all
i [ __ ] love it i go over there i
watch it if i had time i would go to a
game
i think it's great but for you [ __ ]
ian mcfucking
pasty [ __ ] to sit here and try and act
as though
that a bunch of [ __ ] white guys
running around in shorts
and [ __ ] polo shirts tackling each
other
you know is the equivalent
to [ __ ] someone on of of ray lewis's
ability
you're out of your mind you're out of
your [ __ ] mind i tell you right now
you can judge the level
of your sport by the amount of white
guys that are playing it at a
professional level
you can certainly judge the speed of it
okay
rugby looks like you're watching the nba
in the 1960s
you know and hamlet jack steals it oh
applejack
you know and one of the big things that
rugby people always say is they say nfl
players are [ __ ]
okay nfl players are [ __ ] just just
step back and just
wrap your head around that because they
wear pads
you know and you and i get why they say
that because to look at it you're like
oh they have all these pads on
it doesn't hurt then because they have
all this padding on
you know what it is you guys never
played the [ __ ] game
okay i played rugby it was called kill
the man with the ball i've played it yes
i got took knees
and i took shots but you know what i
didn't do i never really led with my
head
and you know why because i didn't have a
[ __ ] helmet on
nobody really led you led with your
shoulder and you tackled with your
shoulder
just like they do in rugby i'm not
saying hey that heads don't collide
i'm not saying there aren't [ __ ]
collisions and broken bones
okay i'm just saying first of all the
helmet
is is uh what you're looking at is an
unbelievable design flaw
what it really is is it's just a
battering ramp it protects the skull it
does not protect the brain
okay do you guys have like when rugby
players are done
playing rugby is their head so [ __ ] up
that they shoot themselves in the chest
so their brain can be donated to science
to figure out what the [ __ ] happened to
him do you have that happening
have you ever had somebody go you know
what uh um
i want to play this week so cut the end
of my finger off so i can
i can go out and actually play this week
you know
do you have people doing [ __ ] like that
you know as they run their [ __ ]
their [ __ ] 10 second 40s over there
look i'm not saying it's a tough game
i'm not saying it's not a [ __ ] you
know
i'm not saying those guys aren't faster
than me but if you put ray lewis
on a [ __ ] rugby field you would be
picking up lim limbs would be littered
all over the field
all right so that's it the debate is
over
and you can [ __ ] do anything you want
to do send me a tweet
send me your [ __ ] emails and all that
type of [ __ ] all right you guys started
it
i never said rugby was a [ __ ] game i
still haven't
you guys constantly send me [ __ ]
emails telling me
that nfl football players are [ __ ]
let me tell you something right now the
average nfl player is big enough
to grab your entire family by the throat
and
choke slam you on your [ __ ] knights
of the round table [ __ ]
table all right so there you go
there's your fodder for this week you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
um oh meanwhile hey by the way my
special is available for download this
week
it's available available for download
for five dollars off of my website
i would appreciate it if you guys would
go on and uh
and download the son of a [ __ ] because
it cost me a lot of money
i'd like to try to make my money back um
and if you could do me a favor
please don't post it on youtube i'm not
having it encrypted and all that [ __ ]
because that's not fair to people who
aren't gonna do something bad with it
just do me a favor okay just give me six
months
just give me a six months window to
[ __ ] sell this thing so i can make my
money back you know
so i can go and make another one so i
don't have to shoot my next special on a
[ __ ] iphone
um if you could do that for me i i would
greatly appreciate it so
here's here's your time to act now at
billboard.com
monday morning you go on you download
the [ __ ] special for five dollars
that is the five deal five bucks can you
can you look into your heart
um um so anyways
oh let's let's let's get let's get one
of these [ __ ] commercials out of the
goddamn way
before before i get going here you know
these people complain christ you didn't
read my commercial until 50 minutes into
a podcast so yeah where
who the hell's even listening anymore
why did i make my password in spanish
huh why would i do that come on
open up no no that's the problem
come on here we go
yeah i went i shot some guns when i was
out here do you know
silencers are [ __ ] legal in florida
they actually had like semi-automatic
rifles with silencers on the [ __ ]
wall i'm going to
got some pictures hopefully posted on
the podcast page of that
um it's [ __ ] hilarious i'm in there
with versi
and they actually uh you know it's
always scary when you when you go to the
gun range
and you're just in there with a bunch of
strangers with loaded [ __ ] guns
um you know and there's always like that
one [ __ ] novice in there that just
you know
or not even they're just so comfortable
they start doing
dumb [ __ ] like loading the gun
on the other side and then turning
around and walking with the [ __ ]
thing up it's like loaded at the at the
i don't know what the terminology is i'm
one of those green horns i probably
shouldn't even be in there but i [ __ ]
i just had that thing pointed down
[ __ ] range
the whole goddamn time i load it right
where i'm gonna shoot it
and when it's done i [ __ ] take the
clip out
i [ __ ] that's it safety on and i just
have it pointed downrange at no point do
i ever take that [ __ ] thing
even pointing it at the floor turn
around and walk
back to whatever the [ __ ] back area
is and then load it there i hate when
people do that [ __ ]
um anyway so i'm actually at the gun
range and this [ __ ] guy comes walking
by he goes hey you bill burr
and i was like yeah he goes i'm going to
see it tonight at the uh comedy zone
i go that's cool right and he [ __ ]
opens up he has like looks like like a
mechanics tool chest
he had like a chrome plated [ __ ]
desert eagle in there
that's a 50 caliber [ __ ] psycho gun
and he had all this [ __ ] with like a
silencer and i go holy [ __ ] dude i go
i go you got a silencer and the guy goes
yeah and you're gonna shoot it
so i'm all excited and then i see versey
versey turns into like a [ __ ]
six-year-old standing there he's got
this look on his face
you know like when the teacher goes who
wants to play with the new toy we bought
and pick somebody else that was the look
versi had on his face like
how come you picked him am i am i going
to get to play with it so i actually
walked always hey is it okay if my buddy
shoots it too and he said yeah
so i tell verzie yes today he's going to
let you shoot it too and he [ __ ] his
whole [ __ ] face lights up right um
it was [ __ ] incredible man it's
[ __ ] incredible
you can't you can't have a silencer or
what do they call a suppressor whatever
the [ __ ] they call it you can't have in
new york if you have one in new york
do you get caught with one of those in
new york i think that's automatically
like [ __ ]
30 years they just look at it like you
have that
because you're planning on murdering
somebody and you don't want anybody to
hear
you know silencer really is sort of the
[ __ ] way of killing somebody right
that's like the passive aggressive
the passive-aggressive route you know
take that um e-voice everybody hey are
you trying to start your own business
and you want to sound more professional
would you like it to sound like you have
a whole
staff of people working for you that you
have this amazing
amazing office wouldn't it be great
wouldn't it be great if you could
somehow
use your cell phone as your personal
phone and your business phone and have
two different numbers
wouldn't that be great to have virtual
numbers
did i say it right yeah virtual numbers
or is it viral virtual virtual phone
numbers
you can have as many phone numbers
basically you can have like upwards of i
don't know how many
numbers all rings on your cell phone
okay they have voice over actors you
know
it's basically your mobile phone at work
evoice is perfect for a
business person on the move like myself
uh features of e-voice offers includes
call forwarding
toll-free 800 numbers auto-attended
advanced voicemail voicemail detects
voicemail to email
um you know what's cool about this
they actually have trained like uh
voice over actors you know you can get
whatever
uh accent you want like some cool
[ __ ] english accent or a french
accent some sexy lady whatever you want
i mean that alone will get people
wanting to come to your office that
doesn't exist
right it's just it's just a great way to
get the business going
or if you already have a business click
on the e-voice banner on billboard.com
podcast page or go to www.evo
evoice.com billbar to get your exclusive
six-month free trial you try this thing
out for six months
e-voice your mobile phone at work there
you go
that's got to be the coolest way to
start your damn business or
start a second family
you know you could live an entirely
different life with that couldn't you
um all right what else we got here
stamps.com everybody
uh when you're running a small business
your hours aren't the traditional nine
to five
you work around the clock so the limited
hours of the post office can be
frustrating that's why you need
stamps.com
get postage on demand right from your
desk whenever you need it 24
7. uh with stamps.com you can buy and
print
official us postage using your own
computer and your printer
you know what's great about that too is
i don't know about you guys but like uh
i'm on the road a lot and when i come
off the road i have like a week and a
half a mail i have to sift through it
and uh i love doing it at night nobody's
calling me
nobody's bugging me i get it done and
the next morning it's all stamped ready
to go
in the damn mailbox and i feel like i
gotta jump on the day
all right so stamps.com you can get
everything from stamps
to shipping labels the instant you need
it then just hand your mail to the
mailman here you go
uh you don't need an expensive postage
meeting meter anymore plus you'll never
have to go to the post office again
okay and who's kidding who who wants to
see those grumpy people
ever again anyways um endorsement
why do i always read the wrong thing um
you can get practically everything on
demand these days
uh like my podcast so why wouldn't you
do the same with postage
using stamps.com it's what i use to send
out my merch for shows it's so
convenient and easy i guess i was
supposed to put that in my own words hey
i send my friggin dvds out with it it's
awesome
what more do you want from me i get to
weigh them on the scale
right now use my last name bur b-u-r-r
for this special offer no risk trial
plus 110
bonus offer includes a digital scale and
up to 55 dollars free postage
um don't wait go to stamps.com before
you do anything else click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in bird that's stamps.com bur
b-u-r-r go no i can't say that it's the
end of the advertising
all right go use it now all right back
to the podcast
so anyways we went and uh we went
shooting
and i got to tell you something it's
it's oddly relaxing
you know what it is uh after you get
over the fact that you're firing a gun
you then want to get good at it and you
want to hit the target it's almost like
you're shooting hoops
except you're shooting at a silhouette
of a person
does that make sense
[Laughter]
um i actually like revolvers
classic me right isn't that just typical
me
the old [ __ ] curmudgeon doesn't like
the new [ __ ]
i'm not into the glocks the
semi-automatics i guess it's nicer that
you have more bullets but
i like the [ __ ] wired-up vibe i just
having a goddamn revolver
you get a nice big one like that 38 that
versi was shooting
the heavier the gun the less kick it's
it's phenomenal
there was this chick next to us shooting
a friggin cannon
that she was afraid of i hate that [ __ ]
i want to go in there i want i want to i
want to go to a shooting range where
it's a bunch of [ __ ] navy seals
and everybody is comfortable this girl
was just like oh man it was a beautiful
gun though
they is it crazy to say that they really
are [ __ ] beautiful
i feel like [ __ ] tom cruise and taps
it's [ __ ] beautiful man
i'm serious the goddamn
[ __ ] they're beautiful is this
freaking everybody out overseas another
uh
american gun nut you know
why don't you guys have guns over there
you know your cops in england the cops
in england don't have guns is that right
or do they have them now because of all
the terrorists
what do they have they have a whistle
and that really tall hat
that's got to slow them down when
they're chasing people just a [ __ ]
lack of aerodynamics wouldn't it
anybody all right here's something you
need to know
oh [ __ ] billy fatface is working out
again and i actually went um this isn't
an advertisement
i went out and i bought a pegboard and
i'm hanging him up in the garage
do i stutter and um
i'm totally i'm [ __ ] all about that
now the grip strength i don't think i'll
ever go to the gym again and [ __ ] sit
there and bench press and all that you
don't need to do it
you just need to do push-ups all you
need to do is move your own [ __ ] body
you don't need to go down there i mean
unless you're trying out for the nfl
you know or you're playing rugby look at
that i gave rugby respect
you know this is what it goes the
lingerie league
rugby and then nfl football bottom to
top you know
um all right let's get to some questions
this week everybody all right uh
college broads college broads
oh by the way you know something you
know the great thing about [ __ ] you
know this rope climbing [ __ ] that i'm
doing doing pull-ups and now i got this
pegboard thing i actually i'm on the
eighth floor of this hotel and i'm
telling you right now
i could climb down the [ __ ] side it's
a bunch of balconies and i could hang
down
from my bow if there was a fire right i
could [ __ ] hang down
and just [ __ ] swing my legs jump down
to the next one and i could just go all
the way down the side of the thing
you know that's right right there
can you do that through bench pressing
and doing squats you can't [ __ ] do
that
you're obese with muscles you're over
developing yourself
all right basically my message is if
you're not doing what i'm doing
you're an [ __ ] despite the fact i
have no
nutritional or training or any of that
[ __ ] i i know what the [ __ ] i'm talking
about
hey let me hype some gigs here uh i'm
next week part of my seven week tour i
am four weeks into this [ __ ] thing by
the way underrated for the week
is the uh the comedy zone in
jacksonville
um florida any other comics are
listening
it's just a [ __ ] old-school comedy
club it's in the ramada
it's got the brick wall behind you i
absolutely [ __ ] love the club
the setup it's just a semi-circle
everybody's right there [ __ ]
phenomenal crowds
i didn't know what i was going to run
into when i came out here did i already
talk about this i started the podcast a
couple of times let me just get right to
it
i had a great time and i'm definitely
going to come back i'd like to come back
um and go to that georgia uh gators game
but i'm just worried that you know the
game's during the day
everybody's going to be [ __ ] hammered
i'm going to get hammered then i got to
do shows no one's going to show up
at some point i have to go to that
goddamn game but anyways i had a great
time and i want to thank everybody who
came out because uh
i was finally able to work out that
hitler stalin thing by adding in
satchel page all right and if it wasn't
such a great club i would have been
closed off and i wouldn't come up with
it so
um so there's that so next week the tour
continues
i'm going to be at go bananas in
montgomery ohio
just outside of cincinnati october 5th
and 6th and
paul dude i called it verzi is going to
be there and we're hanging around to go
to the [ __ ] bengals
dolphins game on sunday that'll be
franchise today's franchise number 110
that'll be franchise 111
111 and i'll have 13 more to go um after
that i'll be
[ __ ] where the hell am i going to be
i'm going to be in new york city
on october 13th at the beacon theater
on the comedy central thing night at too
many stars
there's too many stars people
um well if you're booking me they should
have been a
night of not enough dawn and um all
right
after that then i go to [ __ ]
australia
i'm going to the sydney opera house
october 18th 19th and 20th another great
sport
australian rules football
harrah's in new orleans november 2nd
i've never done stand-up
at any sort of a club in new orleans i
one time i did
i did a club in uh
i don't know northern northern uh where
the [ __ ] was it
louisiana that's what i meant to say not
new orleans i meant in louisiana
i'll be at harrah's november 2nd and on
november 3rd i'm going to lsu alabama
huh you like this [ __ ] people you like
this [ __ ] isn't this [ __ ] is this a
great life
traveling the road i'll be with versi
again it's a phenomenal life you guys
should all try you should all try being
a [ __ ] stand-up comedian at some
point in your life
and then what you do is you continue to
have failed pilots
so you never get a television show and
as much as that hurts one day
it hits you and you realize you know
what it's kind of [ __ ] awesome not to
have a tv show
because i get to kind of just [ __ ] go
out here make great money
go to games do whatever the [ __ ] i want
to do
say whatever i want to say and i don't
have to deal with people going you know
our advertisers are upset by that you
know go [ __ ] yourself
go [ __ ] yourselves that's the thing you
know when you get your own tv show even
if they call it by your own name you
know it's really not your tv show
it's their tv show and they'll take it
back whenever they [ __ ] goddamn
want to and then what do you do you go
out and buy a big
[ __ ] i got my own tv show house and
then all of a sudden you don't have a tv
show but you still got the big i got my
own tv show house
and then what now you got to go on the
road not because you want to because you
have to
and you're going to go out there all
[ __ ] miserable and everybody's
yelling your catchphrase from the show
right you [ __ ] hating life i avoided
all of that
through failed pilots
i am i am i'm living the [ __ ] dream
i just had eggs benedict that were
overcooked did you do that
i laid in a [ __ ] hotel room picked up
the phone
and said listen [ __ ] you bring me those
[ __ ] eggs you bring them to me now
and then another woman knocked on my
door said hey would you like some turn
down service and i said no i would not
but i would like some fresh towels
immediately and she handed them to me
and they were still warm
this is the word of the lord thanks be
to god
all right anybody go to church today
hallelujah
hallelujah you know i sat next you know
you guys think i'm tone deaf i sat next
to one of the most tone deaf people
you know it's underrated a [ __ ] water
taxi i'm looking at one right now
i don't give a [ __ ] if you're going to
the worst [ __ ] job you've ever had in
your life for that moment when you're on
that boat
you're a free man it's like when they
were drinking the beers on the roof and
[ __ ] uh shawshank redemption
um what was i gonna say
the [ __ ] was that oh i sat next to this
lady this lady
you guys think that i'm a bad singer um
which admittedly i am the [ __ ]
uh the lady i was sitting next to
she sat next to me and she goes uh
told me she just came from a george
thorogood concert she goes yeah he just
turned
63 which really made me feel old i go
yeah how was he she goes oh he was great
and then she goes she goes one whiskey
one scotch and one beer
[Music]
[Laughter]
first of all she didn't even get the
words right it's one bourbon one scotch
one beer
and it's i didn't she wasn't even tone
deaf she just for some reason couldn't
remember the melody
how do you not know that that's like one
of his biggest [ __ ] hits off that
cover song
right one bourbon one scotch one big
boob
right one would you go one whiskey one
scotch one beer
[Laughter]
i think she clapped and she was doing it
too one whiskey ones got you one beer
anyway if like if i could have just
[ __ ] skydived out of the plane at
that point i would have it was so
[ __ ] horrific
um and she had a dog
she had a dog with her little duck sound
she had [ __ ] drugged it up
jesus christ this dog was freaking out
it had this [ __ ] fear and
look and it's oh i got a bad feeling man
i was so glad she told me that she
drugged it up but i cuz if
she didn't tell me she drugged it up and
i saw that look in that poor dog's eyes
i would have thought that it knew the
plane was gonna crash you know they
always say that like dogs
dogs can they can sense a [ __ ]
earthquake
it's so [ __ ] dumb can they really
sense an earthquake
or do they just hear it before we do
because they have better hearing
they look at these dumb youtube videos
of the dog sensing it
and it like senses it like [ __ ] six
seconds before people do
that's not sensing it that's just you're
[ __ ] laying on the floor
and you're not wearing any clothes so
you felt the vibrations before i did
because i'm sitting in a chair wearing
shoes
you know if it if it really [ __ ]
could sense it coming it would have
[ __ ] you just see it one day just
packing a suitcase and putting on its
[ __ ] bing crosby fedora
and you'd be like hey lucky where you
going and just be like listen man
you know i know i'm just a dog i don't
wear clothes
i can't drive a [ __ ] car but i'm
telling you it would be in your best
interest to follow me right now into the
wilderness
they never do that they just go oh
like [ __ ] five seconds before you do
and then they just start running
they don't stand in a doorway
you know what it is dogs get [ __ ]
hyped
up because people have been hurt by
other people
you know and at some point they just
you know they want dog they like dog
people wish that people would act like
dogs
just always be excited always be happy
never call them on their [ __ ]
you know just always freak out when i
[ __ ] come home
always do that always be in a good mood
and i gotta admit i'm one of those dog
people i
actually do this thing with nia right
i come home from the airport and i call
her and i and i
i make sure she has the dog like in
another room
so it can't hear me coming up the walk
right it always ends up right as i get
to the walk
you know to head up to the house that
doesn't have air conditioning could we
just get a stand alone unit
um and then she just goes
the second the dog stops because it
hears me close the door to the car
she always goes she just looks the dog
goes who's that
who's that cleo is that daddy
and then she [ __ ] freaks and i hear
her nails is she trying to run across
the hardwood floors [ __ ] slip sliding
she [ __ ] comes just a ball of [ __ ]
muscle
come flying it's the greatest it's the
greatest [ __ ]
it's almost why i do the road just to
watch her freak the [ __ ] out
you know i feel like the teen is
sensation when i come home
ah jesus people where is joe derosa this
weekend
where is that kooky egyptian
all right let's go here all right
college broads
college broads hey bill i'm a freshman
in college right now and i've never seen
so many good looking
ladies in one place in my entire life
ugh and they're all single none of them
are married they don't have any kids
bang them before they get [ __ ] crazy
um
what do we got here he says the problem
is that i have trouble flirting with the
ladies because i always get anxious
around them
how can i start talking to them because
i don't think i'll ever have an
opportunity to meet hot girls like this
again in my life ah dude do you realize
what a what a s what a [ __ ] in the
moment
smart analysis that is you're absolutely
right
you're at like if you're at the club 24
[ __ ] seven
you're living with them all right this
is like the nfl
combine of [ __ ] so start [ __ ] it
you know get out your clipboard and pick
a winner
all right don't go ryan leaf go drew
bledsoe
um i don't know rick meyer that's who
seattle picked
um the pro uh what am i where where how
can i start hot girls
um oh and i've been around so many hot
girls like this again in my life so i
don't make want to make the most out of
these next
four years four f-o-r um
what is the best way to start meeting
these college hotties while i still have
the chance
thanks and go [ __ ] yourself dude there's
only one way to learn how to talk to
ladies
the ladies you just got to start doing
it
okay and give yourself a permission to
suck at it
you know two tours suck at it to suck at
it this is
it's just like doing comedy it's like
learning how to swim they just throw in
the deep end you start kicking that's
all you do don't kick the women that's
not what i'm saying
it was a bad [ __ ] metaphor there or
simile
simile lycoraz no it's a metaphor no i
didn't i didn't say hitting on women is
swimming i said it's like swimming oh
shut the [ __ ] up bill
um yeah just start hitting on him
you know what just what is it
how do you how do you how do you [ __ ]
drop in
you know what it is you're going to
figure out what works for you
you're going to figure you're going to
figure it out do you have a sense of
humor you know what i mean that's always
great if you can make them laugh if you
know
i don't know if you just there's there's
no way
there's no there's no way you just have
to [ __ ] go do it all right
and if you stand there on the wall going
g-shock
but i don't know what you say to her you
know what some
douche who's probably not
you know isn't going to bring as much to
the table as you are right
he it's those [ __ ] who just walk up
to him
and they just hey what do you say there
perfect tits
i'm just [ __ ] with you come on don't
be like that let me get you a drink they
put them in a headlock and they drag
them up to the bar
those guys end up [ __ ] them i mean
that's an oversimplification
and then people like you stand they go
if you is my girlfriend
they retreat you're like dude you're the
biggest princess in the world
right now what happens
he goes out and does what you're going
to go home and jerk off to so what do
you want to do sir do you want to live
in a fantasy world
or do you want to live in reality
[Music]
just go up and talk to him
just do it i don't know do something
just be [ __ ] you know
obnoxious just any anything just try
different things
try going up there and saying something
ron burgundy would say you know
your own i'm kind of a big deal anything
anything to get him [ __ ] laughing
right something
but for the love of god get off the
[ __ ] wall um
sleepwalk banging hey billy boy
i need some advice for something i can
guarantee you haven't gotten an email
about before
this one is personal it's not really
what are you hyping your [ __ ] goddamn
thing just get to it
all right over the last year i have
discovered that i engage in sleepwalking
behavior
the most hilarious part of it i think
[ __ ] mike burbiglio wrote a whole
one-man show that's now a movie about
this so i really don't think you're
breaking new ground
although i'll give you that i'll give
you the benefit of the doubt the most
hilarious part of it is
that i engage in sleep sex
okay you know what go [ __ ] yourself do
you think i'm dumb enough to believe
this
you're either just making this [ __ ] up
or you're a [ __ ] pervert and you're
going around basically sexually
assaulting other people
and then ah i was asleep sorry
did i put my dick on your lip oh my
fault i was sleeping
um anyways let's let's just you know
to fill up the hour i'm going to read
the rest of this but i'm already calling
[ __ ]
because i've been with my girlfriend for
four years now we're both 22 years old
we share a room in a house together
with other housemates and let me guess
you wander in and accidentally [ __ ]
somebody else
is that what you're gonna tell me is
that really where this [ __ ] email is
gonna go
um i found out that if we don't have sex
at least once every two days i will
basically begin to perform sex acts on
her while i
sleep dude you are so full of [ __ ]
[ __ ] i will have absolutely no memories
of these here's his out
oh did i [ __ ] finger bang you with my
dick in your ass sorry i was
sleep sleep sodomizing
i will have no memorize memories of
these in the morning unless i wake up
during the act
my girlfriend says that my eyes are open
but totally glazed over when i do it
the most common one is that i will go
down on her
this is so [ __ ] stupid
you're asleep you're asleep and you're
dreaming
right your eyes are open but you're
you're still like in rem sleep and
you're somehow
pulling the covers off fine what are you
a [ __ ] zombie
uh you know i'm not reading the rest of
this this is the most ridiculous [ __ ]
but you know what maybe there's people
interested i'll keep reading this is the
dumbest thing
this sounds like a scott bail movie from
the list was this the original draft of
zapped
um somebody 43 years old just [ __ ]
did a spit take on the dashboard
with that reference um
where the hell am i i've also
fingered her as well
the one that i am least proud of is that
i apparently
licked my own jizz off her boobs
after all after coming
capital letters all in my sleep
dude this is the most bizarre [ __ ]
thing i've ever read
my girlfriend's actually really cool
about it hey he was sleeping it's fine
honey go like this no on the other side
yeah yeah yeah a little more over there
um at this at first she'll be really
startled because she is sleeping too
if i'm going down our in my sleep she
generally let's
keep going until she comes i'll usually
wake up as she's coming
we'll have sex and we'll both go back to
sleep
oh jesus christ i swear to god people
there's two more paragraphs of this [ __ ]
do you want me to keep going
the scary part to me is the fear of not
having control
over my body and my actions i'm scared
because i have clearly shown my ability
to perform complete tasks
while being completely asleep and having
absolutely no memory of them later
i'm afraid that one day i'll find myself
waking up
driving my car down the highway i
haven't shown myself
doing anything dangerous yet you haven't
shown me you haven't found yourself
but who knows right the only reason i do
know about the times
it has happened so far is because my
girlfriend has been there to tell me it
happened
who knows what crazy [ __ ] i've done
before i met her in my sleep that i'll
never know about my girlfriend says i'm
just being paranoid
and i should let it be wait a minute you
[ __ ] came on your girlfriend's tits
licked your own jizz off of them and
she's like oh you're just being paranoid
is this the white chick from every
[ __ ] horror movie
um i don't think that noise is anything
to be concerned about
um um what would you do would you go see
a therapist or a doctor for this or
would you just let it go i really don't
dude yeah this is beyond he goes i
really don't want to be
go to a doctor with a bunch of pill you
know what i would email mike berbiglia
i actually think i vaguely remember him
talking about
walking over to a window or something
you know and doing something i can't
remember
you know i don't i don't remember i i
would email him oh why don't yeah why
don't you [ __ ] what yeah
go to another comedian no [ __ ] that go
go talk to a professional
all right jesus christ
if that's if that's real is it real sun
is it really real son
um that's one of the big things in
hip-hop everybody's got to deal this is
real son
this is real this is life this [ __ ] is
real
it's like dude it's all real me laying
on a bed right now doing a podcast in
jacksonville that's also real
everything's real son um
yeah if it's actually going on yeah man
i don't i don't know what to tell you
um anyways my girlfriend is blackmailing
me jesus christ dear bill my
ex-girlfriend and i were together for
two months
before she wanted to watch porn with me
i was all hyped thinking that she was
perfect
and and she said she'd pick the porno i
didn't want to make her uncomfortable if
i picked it dude that's a good thing
because if you're too far down the road
you're going to [ __ ] up
the whole thing so that was actually a
very smart
move kudos to you young man um
he goes the night we did she turned on
the video and it was a cartoon
getting raped by it
by a tentacle monster
and an orc orc i don't know what the
[ __ ] that is
i'm not in this world um i was disgusted
and turned it off immediately
and stop having sex with her oh so you
guys were having sex and then she turned
on this [ __ ] horrific cartoon
okay i've seen those i've never watched
one
i've seen those when you go through i've
seen like the cartoons when i go
on the [ __ ] i i want to watch people
banging i don't want to see like you
know
shaggy banging [ __ ] what's her name
daphne
who's the hot one um
anyways i was disgusted and turned it
off immediately stopped having sex with
her she isn't some
geek she's super hot she started crying
saying that i didn't have an open mind i
left and broke up with her
damn at school she spread it around that
i was the one that shows the video
oh there's versi hey versey i'm wrapping
up my podcast
for z i'm wrapping up my podcast
what's going on man nothing i i'm doing
my podcast
jesus christ paul i'm wrapping it up i'm
live right now talking to you let me
call you in like 12 minutes
all right all right is there anything
[ __ ] people just can't get off the
damn
i got to go i got to go oh you got to go
where you going
so anyways uh she isn't some geek she's
super hot she started crying okay
so i broke up with her after school she
spread it around that i was the one that
shows the video
she then blackmailing me blackmailed me
saying
she'd stop if we got back together
ah for [ __ ] sakes joe derose is
calling
ah geez joe i'm doing my podcast you
[ __ ] let me call you back in 10 minutes
ah go [ __ ] yourself joe tell it to
somebody else
um where the hell am i
uh so she she blackmailed me saying
she'd stop
if we got back together she'd stop what
she already told everybody
my friends say i should i should get
back together with her because she's hot
[Laughter]
that is the male brain at 20 years of
age and that
that it i keep her
getting teased
i can't that you [ __ ] up that sentence
dude i don't know if you deleted
something
he said even teachers look at me
differently what should i do
minus throwing my 10-pound textbook at
her head
you know what look dude you know the
real story
and it's gonna be in your face
when somebody comes up to you and it's
like hey i heard you were watching that
[ __ ] uh
octopus raping that chick cartoon video
you just look just be like oh yeah
is that what you heard is that what she
told you
you know why do you give a [ __ ] i know
you might give a [ __ ] because it's your
world
dude the last thing you want to do is
get together with her
this is what you do caller
oh this is what you do oh i got it
here's what you do
is what you do why don't you just
[ __ ] record a phone conversation with
her
or have her come over all right
you [ __ ] hit record on your [ __ ]
smartphone
you ever come in and just say listen i'm
sorry i broke up with you
i'd really like to get back together
with you but you have to promise
me you will stop telling people
that lie or whatever and you get her to
admit it
and then you just talk to her for 10
minutes why are you why do you think
you're into stuff like that and you get
it to admit the whole [ __ ] thing
and then in the end just go you know
what
i just realized i don't want to get back
together with you and then you kick her
out
because [ __ ] her and her feelings at
this point all right
and then you let it spread the [ __ ]
rumor and then what you do is you just
upload onto your [ __ ] page the audio
and then you become [ __ ] oh no no no
don't do that don't do that because then
that that's all [ __ ] mean this is
what you do
you [ __ ] hit stop and just say listen
i'm gonna tell you something no then the
next day when you guys are allegedly
together
you meet up with her in a coffee shop
like [ __ ] mickey rook
in the end of [ __ ] the pope of
greenwich village and
you say listen [ __ ] we're not getting
together and you're gonna stop saying
that [ __ ] about me
you know why because i got a tape a tape
i took off a dead cop and you [ __ ]
punch the side of her hand just like
you're talking to bert young
okay then you put [ __ ] lie in a
coffee charlie no you don't do that
that's what you do
just [ __ ] recorder and this is the
thing
don't put it on your facebook page just
have it on your phone
okay and at any point anybody comes up
to you and says it just say oh yeah
listen to this
and then you play it for him and say
there go [ __ ] yourself
and then that's it and eventually it'll
get back to her that you have that
[ __ ] recording
and then she'll shut the [ __ ] up but
don't don't put it on your facebook page
because then somehow there'll be some
sort of cyber bullying and at the end of
it she has a vagina and you have a dick
so somehow you'll end up being wrong
you know because if there's one thing
i've learned the ladies
are never wrong in the public eye
because they can't bench press as much
as us that's basically what it comes
down to
all right here we go so that's what you
do sir just pretend like you're getting
back together with her and then go into
an in-depth conversation about why she's
into those videos and why she would go
out and hurt you like that when you
would never do something like that to
her
okay don't say you're going to get back
together just say i want to talk about
this i have to think about this and just
delve into all of that
and ask her why she would do something
like that and then in the end just
be like you know i don't know
i need to think about this and then you
walk dramatically over to the window
and she and then she goes so does that
mean we're back together and then you go
get out
just get out and then then you got the
tape and then you're good and anybody
gives you any [ __ ] just say i got audio
of her talking about why she's into it
all right and then call her and then
call her tell her just say listen i
recorded that conversation last night so
uh i i it's in your best interest to
shut the [ __ ] up
all right so why don't you go find a
squid to shove in your [ __ ]
and leave me out of it and that's the
news and i'm out of here uh
bill should i fly the coop and leave my
boring boyfriend
yes absolutely
that's it i don't even need to read it
you're thinking about leaving because
your boyfriend boards the [ __ ] out of
you
you know if you want longevity you got
to have somebody that keeps your [ __ ]
heart going a pity patter
um dearest billiam how's it going i'm a
32 32 year old
lady in need of some advice i moved to a
new place
about a year ago to be with my boyfriend
and everything with him is perfect we
laugh a lot the sex is great and rarely
argue
it's a dream my issue is where we live
and who we live with oh [ __ ] this has
nothing to do with him see this this is
why you read them
um where the hell am i here
uh we laugh a lot sexist but my issues
is where we live
and who we live with i hate the area
that we live in
and my guts thinks we live in a paradise
oh and my guy thinks we live in a
paradise and doesn't want to move
we also live with the mean ass relative
of his
that he is caring for oh jesus
oh jesus okay first of all i'm just
going to say you're a saint
for actually putting up with this this
long not being married to somebody and
you're [ __ ] with their goddamn in-law
or some [ __ ]
um i helped take care of this surly [ __ ]
too but i'm over it
i'm thinking about bailing ship i feel
bad about it because one who am i
kidding i'm old and the baby machine is
ready for distribution
two the guy i'm with is honestly the
nicest person that i've ever met
anything you and the lovely nia can
suggest would be appreciated by the way
thanks for making the beginning of my
week a little better
oh look at you you're a sweetheart all
right c love this guy you just have to
sit down with them and just be like
listen
sweetheart we're better than this okay
you know i hate living here
at the very least i think you would be a
lot happier
if you could just not be living with the
surly [ __ ]
you know is there any way you guys can
live someplace
nearby can you have that surly [ __ ] like
in a shed
you know like that slingbail
slingblade's brother that they buried in
that hole in the backyard
you know can you just can you can you go
down to home depot and just buy some
sort of [ __ ] four-walled structure
with a roof and just stick that [ __ ]
in there
with a uh you know with an
air-conditioned wall unit
can we get a wall unit at least um
yeah i don't think that you know if you
really love this guy you shouldn't leave
him over this but like
if this guy loves you you can actually
sit down and have a conversation and
just be like listen i'm miserable
you know if i was ever with nia and
she's just like listen i [ __ ] hate la
i can't deal with this anymore i i gotta
get out of here
you know now if she said i want to go
live in kansas i'd be like well i don't
think i can make a living out there
we need to talk but you know she wants
to go back to new york i would go back
you know so who knows just have the
conversation have you had a conversation
with them have the conversation see how
it goes
and then [ __ ] write me back let me
know what's up all right
that's it that's it all right underrated
comedy zone in jacksonville already said
that youtube video of the week
all right i got this one for you this is
a deep purple video
new york 1973 live concert
they're [ __ ] amazing but and also you
gotta you gotta you gotta listen to this
at 5 46 in the video
this this [ __ ] epic moment happens
right here let me make sure i turn this
up
this happens right here
yeah just for that
i think he was out trying to he was
trying to out robert plant robert plant
um all right that's the podcast for this
week
uh thank you to everybody came out to
the shows i'm really looking forward to
go to
go bananas in cincinnati my [ __ ] hour
i got it it's down [ __ ]
i got the new hour you will show up even
if you download my special tomorrow
watch that thing
wire to wire memorize the whole thing
you will not see one repeated joke
okay all brand new [ __ ]
i'm bringing the fire [ __ ] is real um
that's a podcast for this week uh
please download it onto youtube
please don't do that just like i said i
don't give a [ __ ]
in like six months if you want to put
some clips up there at that point you
know whoever's gonna buy it
is gonna [ __ ] buy it i don't give a
[ __ ] just just give me the chance to
[ __ ] make my money back
all right keep in mind that
billy burr has to make his money back
or his next special will be a cd
audio [ __ ] only go [ __ ] yourself
for all ages go [ __ ] yourselves i'll
talk to you next week